hey guys it's the Evan and Kaitlyn
podcast episode number 42 which has the
answers to life the universe and
everything so that's from the
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy from
Douglas Adams it's a reference oh well
maybe not you know I thought it was very
clever thank you just to a year's worth
of episodes yeah we started January 1st
and I think that we have only skipped
one week yeah over the past year so
we're getting really close to one year
we're almost well I don't know this
isn't exciting at all I just notice
they're almost a thousand posts on
into-into posts we need to make sure
that that one is a good one in
particular no one else will notice so
today we're gonna be talking about
YouTube Netflix quality and quantity and
comparing like what different strategies
are like quality versus quantity of
videos specifically yeah and also how
well auto saw to say that crazy
statistic up front YouTube is now more
popular than Netflix between thirteen
and twenty four year olds really really
that's interesting I know that's crazy I
know more people like more people in
that age range they turn to YouTube as
opposed to Netflix and that's their
favorite and that's where they watch
more content so we're gonna be talking
about that later first things life stuff
it is approaching Halloween and we have
a yearly tradition we've for the past
nine years with one year break we have
gone to the same haunted house because
it is awesome yeah it's um this is like
the one Halloween tradition that like no
matter well except from that one year
last year last year we had to skip it
because October was an insane month for
us and it is again this year but we
weren't gonna let it stop us from going
to this haunted house it's like I mean
should we talk about what it's called
scare freak here it's in Austin and it's
not really a haunted house it's an
interactive experience where basically
you are the protagonist in a horror
movie and you get
interact with the environment and
there's actors and you go in with a
group of like six max people yeah so
it's not like it you know a lot of
traditional haunted houses are like ones
that you know amusement parks and stuff
you're just in a line like a train you
can see up ahead like oh there's a scare
up there because I heard someone scream
or I saw that person get jumped out but
this is just you and your small group
it's immersive it's very immersive you
get immersed in blood yeah you do you do
actually you have to sign a waiver and
there's you know like a video up front
that you have to watch every year that's
like if you're someone who reacts
violently when startled it like not for
you because it's all so it's all like
volunteer based and they put it together
every year it's a different theme every
year and it's all volunteer actors and
it's just it's it's so it's the most
elaborate haunted house again it's not
really haunted house it's like a haunted
exhibition that sounds I'm sure yeah
it's the most elaborate thing that I've
been to and it's so crazy and it's great
too because it's volunteers that are
running it and it's a non-profit and all
of the proceeds go to raise money for
breast cancer yeah and it's like that's
that's awesome and it's everything about
it is good yeah it's so cool and like by
the end of it you're such a mess like we
are covered in blood we've crawled
through dirt yeah and like you're
crawling through these tunnels and then
you like you get to a dead end and you
can't go any farther but then they
closed both ends of the tile in your
trap and then the whole tunnel swings to
another area of like the adventure and
it's yeah it's insane or we were in like
an elevator shaft yeah that like the
elevator was supposed to go down a
certain Mountain then it crashed and it
went all the way down yeah but it's like
it's different every year it's different
there was a clown one there's a fantasy
one there's a zombie ones at summer camp
one fairytale one this one was like
blood and stones is kind of like a
temple based yes I'm sure yeah it's
really cool and Halloween is Caitlyn's
favorite time of the year and we just uh
you know if we didn't make time for this
we probably wouldn't do anything Holi
except for like giving out candy on
Halloween yeah I mean we used to go to
like Halloween parties and stuff but we
don't really do that anymore and
everyone has grown up and moved in
different areas and everyone's doing
everyone's separate so our group that we
used to parties with that doesn't really
happen anymore
and so this is an important tradition we
need something to mark Halloween we need
to get covered in blood and run around
for two hours and that's the crazy thing
too this haunted house experience lasts
for two hours and it does not feel like
that no it goes by so fast there's also
like there's this little story based
thing but then there's nothing called
the boneyard which is a maze and it's
the scariest part honestly because for
the the main story you have like guides
and stuff and you do get scared there's
definitely like jump scares and super
creepy stuff but like with the boneyard
you can only go in two people at a time
and it's just you have no idea what this
is awesome amazed and there's people
with chainsaws and scary masks and
things where you don't know if their
people are not and they get yeah you
know they chase you they like seriously
chase you around the maze and my I have
a really good sense of direction and
since we've been there so many times the
exit has always been in the same place
and I was able to keep track but also
I'm tall so I can like see over a lot of
fences so I was trying to get into this
one direction but the exit wasn't in
that direction and I kept on trying to
go there and I kept on getting lost and
I'm like what the heck
I know it's over here but it wasn't it
was in a completely different direction
and Caitlyn has ditched me with our
other friends and she ran off and she
escaped and I was still in there trying
to get out all by myself with you scary
people okay we were so lost that our
other friends who had you know they had
like wait till they could come in caught
up with us
yeah and that we got separated because
we were getting chased by a chainsaw and
the last thing I heard as I was saying
hey guys
[Laughter]
it was an accident we were running for
our lives yeah but we want to do one
more thing to mark Halloween so I think
maybe next podcast we might do some
scoop scoop e spooky stories you might
tell some scary stories around a
campfire or something yeah we can do if
it's cold enough we were gonna do it for
this one but it's like it's really hot
in the high 80s it's too hot to be your
campfire so maybe maybe for the next
podcast yeah maybe for the next one
other updates the main channel we how
many videos got was I guess two videos
ago we launched the cat kiss and that
was number one of our past ten videos
very exciting I think we touched on that
briefly in the last podcast so we're so
excited was doing well and then we
launched another video the guest room
and that was number one then number two
but like did we already talk about how
that makes us feel if you know what
we're doing a little bit it makes us
yeah it's it's it's hard when I think
every youtuber doubts like have I lost
it like do I not even know what my
audience wants anymore do I not know how
to make videos am i moving in the wrong
direction well in it even people that
like you look at them from out from the
outside and you're like they have it
together they they know the message of
know we've talked to them they don't
either do I think we had a whole podcast
of like we don't know what we're doing
like I think that it's interesting that
that just doesn't seem to go away and
coming up with ways to deal with that
not that we've really come up with ways
to be able it's just like a constant
thing that literally everyone you watch
is probably figuring out it makes us
wonder how many times do we have to go
through this how many times does our
content have to like draw up in
viewership and then pick back up again
friends I understand that it's a cycle
channel dang I never with this I didn't
never thought the channel like dive had
a couple duds in a row but did maybe
think like are we moving in the right
direction do we need to evaluate things
I thought we knew what we're doing and I
thought we're moving in a good direction
but now the statistics aren't showing
that and then
what's that it was we had a period of
lower views and it was broken by the the
cactus which doesn't have any resin in
it but we had a little period of lower
views when we hadn't done any resin
projects and I was like oh god does that
mean we have to do resin every single
time I mean I love resin and seriously
become the resin channel I don't want to
become the resin Channel yeah well
they're our next video is rest I mean
we're trying to stick to our guns of
doing what we're most excited about and
and I think that we are doing a good job
of that but you know of course I don't
know I don't really know where I was
going with that but I think that's just
like I'm just really excited to have
like two videos in a row that are moving
in a good direction that are doing well
and I'm like okay I'm kind of like
breathing a sense of relief still like
well I think that's especially important
right now because I know we've mentioned
it a couple of times but October is
extra extra crazy and so we've we've
been working even even more than we
normally do we already like work
probably an unhealthy amount but it's
been even more stressful so at least
having the videos were putting out
perform well does have balanced it a
little bit if we were going through all
of this and our videos were like bombing
I'd be like what are we doing what I
mean like we have tried to make plans
and you know like we mentioned before
you know are we plan our videos months
in advance so we can't really make rapid
agile adjustments but in January we're
gonna try to take to buffer weeks yeah
in January and try to like catch up on
life things then like get get on top of
things a little bit so ya know we are
fingers crossed for us
fingers crossed unless something comes
up that's crazy but you know who knows
where we're trying which I'm also on the
gaming channel fun interesting update we
launched our fifth channel over there
like related to gaming the evident Galen
gaming uncut Channel and it just got
monetized very exciting we have made $0
so far because it just happened
still very exciting still very exciting
you know I don't know I'm glad that
people are enjoying it and watching
those videos and then and everything it
feels like all of the pain I went
through to upload all those old videos
is worth it it was like days days of
work I know but I'm at like hours and
hours of content yeah probably a day's
worth of content if you added up all the
hours yeah oh yeah definitely like cuz
each each one was like 2 to 3 hours oh
well we're getting some great feedback
from you guys we've got a few comments
of people who have said like when
they're when they're working or modeling
I've seen a tweet from someone I know
there's that I saw you they love putting
that on in the background while they
work they've gone through the entire
thing once and they're already on their
second box okay the whole season
minecraft is a story you know and it's a
unique story for every single person
that plays it so it's so interesting how
like that game just by its nature create
something interesting yeah it's really
cool yeah it's just an exciting thing I
want to share with you guys and
celebrate with you okay so the YouTube
verse Netflix YouTube being more popular
what are your thoughts because that it
was a statistic that really surprised me
that YouTube is doing better than
Netflix which is like this thing that
like you know so much money so much
professionalism so much time goes into
and yet people are turned into YouTube
instead of Netflix and I think that kind
of ties into a similar topic of the
quality versus quantity so let's do one
at a time yeah okay
so interestingly if I was looking at
like 13 to 16 year olds or so yeah that
makes sense I feel like they do watch a
lot more YouTube than Netflix but I
wouldn't have guessed that the older
half of that age bracket also does more
YouTube than Netflix yeah and it doesn't
make sense that like beyond that like
people older than that watch more
Netflix yeah um well like you tubers
catching up and had age range is like
this study that was done on this age
range I'm not sure what it is for older
people but
but it's just interesting that the
YouTube is passing up Netflix for the
firt like 2019 is the first year that's
crazy
where the viewership was was larger
that's so crazy yeah and it it's also
interesting because so we were listening
to a it was like a Joe Rogan podcast
where he interviewed Jim Gaffigan and
they were talking about like getting
Netflix specials and this and that and
working with Netflix and I was just
thinking oh my gosh that's that's you
give up so much control to put your
stuff out there yeah you have a platform
but it's so crazy because if if YouTube
is becoming the main like source of
entertainment for such a huge age range
I'm sure that's gonna keep I could see
that keep keeping on growing and it's
like you can just you know go around all
that have self publish and then you
control it you are in full control of
your own work that you put time into
yeah which is just insane to me
yeah and like it's also just the the
budget difference is amazing I think of
like a scripted Netflix show yeah
there's so much time and money and
there's more and more Netflix originals
coming out every single year okay and
they're good good get this this is gonna
blow your mind this is the statistic
that I've saved for later
stranger things yes amazing show yeah
huge hype huge budget those actors are
like really famous now how many views do
you think it got on its opening weekend
how many views in total unique views
yeah I don't know okay 23 million so
that that seems wow 23 million that's a
lot a lot guess I'm not shamed awesomes
first video in his Jeffrey star series
is app I don't know 22 million that's
insane that's insane and it's gonna grow
yeah and then the videos get to like 19
million or so in like that first few
days of their launch but it's insane to
me that a single person and his editor
two people yeah small team a budget of
like nothing
yeah can can create a piece of content
that gets and you know the cultural
impact who knows about like whatever
says I'm just kind of going based on
views and everything and of course you
know stranger things might have a longer
lifetime then change awesome series I'm
not sure what it is like what another
thing to think about is went on launch
day of stranger things it launches with
an entire season so it can rack up more
views oh yeah I guess people are binging
whereas Shane releases one week at a
time but if you added up the first 24
hours of each of his videos yeah like
like one of you counts through all of it
I'm not sure this is his account but
basically it's like kind of comparable
which is insane to me that that content
being created on YouTube is competing
with Netflix so one to one yeah and
because like okay yeah
choosing Shane - awesome series which is
like one of the biggest things on
YouTube right now may not be fair in a
way but stranger things is like one of
the best thing is that Netflix has
that's it's like it's still like the
whole you know whatever yeah but it also
kind of goes to show you that like
Netflix can make so much money because
it has that legitness that like you know
corporate polish of like you know you
can put your ad money behind us we're
Netflix and we make content that Netflix
doesn't it out yeah yeah so it's just
subscriptions really yeah yeah Wow
that blows my mind yeah like how are
they making money I don't know oh yeah I
don't think they have ads
it's just subscription that's crazy to
me I guess people just like get a
subscription and like hang on to it
you know I mean like you know we don't
pay for our Netflix subscription we we
just a gone with your parents like so
many people relate to everyone just like
shares their Netflix login but you know
it's like yeah you're oh you just need
that flicks and you just subscribe and
you just kind of keep it as like a habit
my Netflix needs to stay relevant
otherwise people are going to start
because unsubscribing ennui to start
watching something on Netflix cuz really
yeah we have it this one looks kind of
interesting let's throw that on just
because we didn't have any of our
YouTube shows that we've not regularly
watch more YouTube the Netflix yeah when
we think of a show to watch me think
okay is there anything as are any of our
favorites have they any of them released
something on YouTube nope okay let's see
what's on Netflix maybe and we've only
done that just recently because we've
just started running out of new shows
yeah but it's uh it's interesting and I
guess that kind of ties into the
discussion of quality versus quantity
and there's there's so much that we have
to say about this Caitlyn and I talk
about quality versus quantity a whole
bunch in so many different contexts
within our content a lot we think about
it within other types of channels some
channels put out a lot of content but
because they put it out so rapidly they
can't take on as big of a project
whereas you know when you look at a
channel like Shane Dawson you know he
puts a lot of time into like a single
video and there's a long wait period
between his like series and then even
beyond that quality versus quantity
discussion there's also YouTube first
Netflix
you know and like so when you're saying
YouTube first Netflix is YouTube's
quantity like what do you what how are
you making that comparison YouTube is
kind of quantity and Netflix is more
quality and air quotes because like
YouTube kind of almost as a platform
YouTube just has so much content and
that's kind of how its competing against
Netflix because no matter like who you
are you can find your niche on that foot
on YouTube and like find a community
almost in the way I think and that's not
to say that YouTube doesn't have quality
it's just I would say like quantity is
far just far exceeds like the quantity
on Netflix and from that quantity you're
gonna find quality and it also depends
on how you define and quality you know I
mean a lot of things on Netflix the
majority of things on Netflix are shot
on professional cameras they have
dollies and rigs and jigs and they have
like mold
camera people and audio equipment
everywhere and they're all technically
in that produced yeah a lot of ways but
like how important is that to people
nowadays and I think the surprising
answer is like not important
yeah for me it's definitely not that
important like it there needs to be a
minimum standard of like I need to be
able to hear the audio and it has to not
hurt my ear I got it some of Shane's
videos we're a little bit like oh I wish
they had of like used better equipment
or whatever but like that might have
like there's a couple parts as hard to
hear the audio part yeah but I still
think that the like story of whatever
I'm watching is more important like it
needs to be engaging and that's more
important than having like the best
audio or the best video yeah like is the
content good and is it something that I
want to watch and I think that that for
I don't know us and a lot of people I
guess III just don't find scripted TV
which is what Netflix basically is to be
as interesting as kind of a lot of
unscripted things yeah I mean there's a
couple exceptions like I mean the only
current one I can think of is stranger
things that's the only scripted show
really that we watch and we're like
still not even done with the season like
four episodes and so behind and like you
know we liked Game of Thrones until the
end
oh my gosh there is some scripted stuff
but I feel like it's just maybe not what
we watch but we're not the best examples
cuz we watch maybe 20 minutes of a show
a day yeah and I think that yeah so
there's not very much not very much yeah
but it's interesting so going back to
like quality first quantity for our own
channel or other youtubers it's
something that we thought about a lot
especially like with October being so
crazy you know you can't help it
brainstorm like well would it be better
if we only did one video a month but
then it needs to be a much like a bigger
project to to justify only doing one a
month and
that's so much pressure so much pressure
on it performing super well yeah you'd
have a lot more time to make it really
good but there's so much pressure and
it's like if you don't have a sponsor on
that video that's one twelfth of your
sponsor income for the year out the door
if something doesn't work out where is
it for us if a sponsor doesn't work out
like it's still annoying but it's not
such a huge chunk because we have a lot
of opportunities and same with it video
flops it's like it sucks but you know
it's only one of the like three to four
videos we're doing that month and so
it's hard to know what's what's more
appealing and then there's people who
upload every day or like five times a
week and that seems super stressful but
at the same time there is a little bit
of pressure relief in that way because
you know if you're if you're just
looking at how many views you get per
week you know if you want just to make
it easy if you want 500k views per week
then you either have to do one 500k view
worthy video or you could do five 100k
viewer thee videos yeah and in some ways
that makes those videos it puts a little
bit less pressure on them even though it
requires more time from you and it's
just interesting because there's a
give-and-take and we have friends that
post once a month and we have friends
that post five times a week and I think
they're equally stressed yeah there's
something that we thought of like you
know we could produce more casual videos
in between these big ones or like break
the big ones into more parts yeah like
that doesn't sit right with me really
well I don't really want that either I'm
just using it as an example so like Alex
steel for example yeah cuz you know he
might make a sword and it might be 20
parts yeah you know and that's how he's
able to do bigger projects but still
upload or there's another thing that we
could do we could hire an editor and you
know you I think can take our videos to
a much better place but you know when
we've like you know like for the gaming
channels worked out well because that
style has developed on its own but like
when we bring on an editor we lose some
of Kaitlyn's style that she's been like
putting into this so if we brought on an
editor would lose a little bit of what
makes our videos our videos which would
be painful to us and I think that not
that would make our videos necessarily
worse but it'd make them different from
our current trajectory which would be
kind of jarring to our audience but
that's save us a ton of time and we
could you know get a lot of time in our
life back or we could make more videos
if we had someone else editing them but
the quality I think not in terms of like
objective but like relative to what
we're doing now would drop in our
audience's eyes and what would the value
of that be I think you know well I mean
yeah I think the hard thing is like we
are in the Edit I constantly experiment
with stuff and we tweak things and you
know because I edit the videos as we go
not just in one big chunk at the end it
allows us to change course mid video
yeah that's invaluable yeah yeah and
that's super valuable and I feel like
we'd be more if if we said okay so let
me back up so last October yes about a
year ago we started experimenting and
we've mentioned this before but we tried
hiring out the Edit of a few videos and
you know it worked it worked well he was
a solid editor but what we realized is
we wanted to it was really hard to
communicate when we wanted to do
something different than what we had
done before because there wasn't like a
model to follow and we were feeling the
need to keep on tweaking our style and
it was just really you know it's hard
enough just to communicate what you want
to a person but then when you kind of
want to change things but you don't know
how you want to change them yet that's
like impossible to UK make that
different and better or just like make
it make it feel kind of more like this
vibe like what does that mean so I like
I wonder if we had kept on hiring out
the editing how our videos would
different now oh wow like would they be
a lot more similar to how they were a
year
would be kind of because we if you if
you look back you know we did there were
definitely some similarities but we've
also changed a decent amount and it's
it's interesting to think about if the
editing style would have evolved and
likewise if we decided today like okay
we're gonna hire out all of our videos
does that mean the videos would stay as
they are now you know and what unknown
trajectory are we missing out on yeah so
it's yeah it's just really hard to hire
out I think in terms of like the quality
versus quantity thing I think that I
think that will eventually hit a median
medium yeah I feel like we're getting
close and it's hard because you always
compare yourself to other people and so
like some channels we watch put out
videos every week but then you know so
then you think like well I should put
out a video every single week but then
you find out either those those channels
have a team of five people or their
channels where the videos take 48 hours
max to film and edit the whole thing
yeah
and that's not the case like the week
was just defined like seven days was
defined I was like the arbitrary period
in which you need to put out videos like
every seven days you need to put out a
video and that's like only because the
the the week structure is already in
place
remember like Friday mornings find a
morning is yet best that's when they put
out their videos but it's so interesting
that like like what if our weeks had
have been nine days long change the
calendar yeah like it's just like
everyone decided like a long time ago
that there's gonna be seven days in a
week and that's what we structures are
structured are our lives around to some
arbitrary time of every seven days yeah
yeah it is interesting to think about
yeah yeah I think like we we're trying
to put a little bit less pressure on
ourselves because making things does
take a lot of time
hmm like all of our projects take
several days to film in several days to
edit so if we if it takes us you know
six days or less that I mean it's it's
rare that it takes us like under five or
six full days when you count everything
that has even when you think you're done
then you have a thumbnail then you have
the metadata sponsor approvals you're
gonna go in and tweak audio in color and
this is an ad and it always takes us
longer than we think yeah
so I I don't really see us ever upping
the quantity mm-hmm and I know that like
you know we've gotten requests from our
audience before or like I wish you guys
would make more videos but you really
don't want us to make more videos yeah I
mean they wouldn't be good but they
would have to be different they'd have
to like and it's not just like three
videos a week or three videos a month
would be like they are now and then
there'd be one bonus one adding that one
bonus one takes away time from all the
other three it's not just like
additional content and it's okay if that
additional one you know is only watched
by some people because it would bring
down the time we have to put towards
that me and also I think that it's
interesting this just even within the
podcast we've gotten a few comments like
some people really love the games some
people don't like the games but some
people have said like you know the games
take away time from the topics topics
but those are just in addition when
we're done with the topic we're done
with the topic we like have run out of
things to say yeah because generally we
just talk about things until we're done
then we move on yeah but I think that in
general we're just realizing that things
take the time they take and we're just
becoming okay with that and also like
even the podcast it's like we're trying
to like not make it a certain time so
even if today's podcast is a little bit
shorter which we're expecting it to
probably be that's okay yeah but I guess
so you're you're saying that to tie it
back to how you know with the podcast
and using the podcasts and games for
example if we add on a game it's not
taking away time for the rest of podcast
but like if we add extra video every
month it that does take away yeah tempos
and the other
yeah yeah this is just a lot
what would you I wonder like what we
would do differently if we were only
uploading once a month I think that I
would really like to spend some time
designing really cool stuff
yeah like or trying new things that have
never been done before put a lot of time
and research and experimentation and
like you know find a way to like bring
in the experimentation into the build
video and like experiment with new video
types and everything and it's just like
I think that right now we just need to
go with more known things I think we I
think actually if we were doing only one
a month we would not be able to
experiment with video types as much
because like I said you only have one
chance a month so I feel like you'd have
to tone down your experimentation like
in one month if we're doing three videos
and we want to try something new we can
add 10% of the new thing in one video
and then another 10% then another 10% I
got something like crazy like not make
it messing with the format of the video
about like you know putting a lot of
time into the design like the 3d
modeling making it like you know adding
more clever things or like putting more
time and like what the thumbnail will be
to get more clicks you know like working
on like a concept that is like what I
need to click on that I need to see that
you know so we put more time into
researching the concept to get very
clickable and viral worthy and stuff
like that then we put a lot of time into
the design I mean not that we don't put
time into any of that so we put a lot
but it is limited you know which is so
that's interesting because I think
sometimes that extra brainstorming time
might lead to a like bigger project or a
bigger build or you know something that
takes longer to film and make and
sometimes I might not like for example
the just going back to the catcus that's
I mean that video did take a little bit
longer due to like dried time but it
wasn't like ridiculously longer to film
than a normal project and the project
wasn't like so
physically huger than something else but
like like like taking that concept one
thing we could have done is we could
have built one cat kiss and then taking
it and and shown it to other cats like
taking it to a shelter and like you know
seeing how other cats react we can like
take concepts and take them farther and
maybe that print spikes that's like one
thing I wanted to do spikes for the
capture oh yeah we could have like taken
it like even farther you know taking
concepts farther and like bring them out
into the world and stuff like that but
it's interesting I guess I'm kind of
playing devil's advocate here because
what I was getting at is sometimes you
might spend more time brainstorming but
the projects itself wouldn't end up
being something that like from the
outside
feels like it justifies a month of wait
time because sometimes like the
brainstorming and the idea that doesn't
mean that magic takes like it takes
longer to build and I think especially
when your videos are like making
something if you do something that seems
like oh they they could just make that
in two days yeah then people might get
like annoyed that you're not posting
more I don't know it's something that I
worry about yeah it's interesting cuz
like making something adds more time to
the process but at the same time you
know it does define a period of time
also what do you mean so it's like if if
someone is making a film and you know
there's like story and other thing
that's like if people are making a more
ambitious youtube upload
not around making something you don't
know how long it took them to like bring
all the people together coordinate all
those things as you know like there's so
many more unknowns that like you could
assume oh well that just took a long
time or you know maybe took them a long
time to build that set or put together
the thing or whatever it is but for
building something it kind of like
building something we kind of defined
the days we define the timeline of it
and like in the build video it it kind
of outlines how long it took you to to
make it see how many outfit changes
there were and that's how long or like
you know we do it through the one sleep
late or not everyone does
but at the same time people have an idea
in their head of how long it takes to
make something what they don't see is
all the time after the editing and the
filming and all the time before I like
designing stuff okay yeah but like with
a piece of content that's not around
making something that time is indefinite
you know sort of I mean I think it
depends on what it is it does to find
out what it is yeah yeah yeah I don't
really know I was going with this to
move on to thing of the week yeah sure
my thing of the week is polypropylene
yes this will make sense when you see
Friday's video basically we love working
with resin and the one downside of
working with resin is that it's very
adhesive it loves to stick to things you
know one thing that it doesn't like
sitting - hey so you can get sheets of
it and you can use it in resin projects
and it has a very nice clean release and
it is gonna be so useful going forward
in the front prop in the future like I
knew that polypropylene and resin work
well together and that they don't stick
together because of chemicals and I
don't know things I am science but I
like knowing that and having used it now
you'll see how I use it later this week
but it's just like my mind is going in
lots of different directions and opens
up lots of different possibilities for
the future and I'm really excited about
it well I think one of the biggest
things is because because we've tried
various things on our videos that don't
stick to resin so we've tried like
lining something with tyvek tape that
technically works we've tried parchment
paper that works but it got wobbly and
warp II we tried making our own silicone
molds has its advantages and
disadvantage that works but silicone
takes a super long time pure tone takes
the finish of whatever the master model
is exactly what the master model isn't
perfectly shiny you don't get something
perfectly with parchment paper and same
with Tyvek tape you know there's gonna
be seams yeah so whatever you have
whatever that surface is that you're
putting the resin on it's going to take
the surface finish of it and polishing
resin to get it
to its full glass shine is like the
worst thing the worst we just like it so
much it takes so long to get it perfect
and like the dust is nasty and all sorts
of stuff and polypropylene is glass
smooth so it gives you that glass like
finish without you having to polish it
now you have to use like clean
unscratched polypropylene which now this
is sometimes hard the one I like a new
sheet every time I and the supplier that
we bought ours from doesn't didn't come
with a protective sheet so there were
some like tiny very small little
scratches and stuff but still the result
we got out is amazing so I definitely
see us like ordering more of that in the
future working with it more and I'm just
excited that's that's my thing and it
it's this week so that's my thing of the
week good good words okay so mine is
actually an Instagram account and so
when we've been following a bit and so
the account is those nerdy design
sketches and when did we first find her
was it when she did the t-shirt for
tested I think we just found it just
because it was on the recommended
recommended page but she does nerdy
sketches of social she'll do little
sketches of things from like video games
and she does little call-outs almost as
if it's like a concept drawing so she'll
have like a sh Ketchum's hat and then
like a little call out with like a fact
about it or she'll have the hallway from
the shining with little call-outs and
facts is this like a satisfying picture
to look at
yeah it's personally satisfying art
they're really well done and it's what I
like to do is like um I like looking at
it before I read what it is to see if I
can like recognize what it's from you
know so most the times I'm like oh yeah
I know for sure I don't know it's like a
movie I haven't seen or something yeah
so I like I like watching and or I like
looking at them and see if I can guess
but just if you like movies and video
games and stuff like that
you should follow those nerdy design
sketches on Instagram oh you know it's
sad huh we almost made this episode
forty-two minutes long Oh episode 42
let's talk for three more minutes okay
bonus topic time bonus topic okay um
weather let's let's do a preview of
scary stories for next podcast do you
have one um you know it's interesting I
don't have that many scary stories that
have happened to me I know you've had
some and your parents have had some and
I've had friends that have had some at
my house oh okay I'll tell I'll tell one
kind of scary story that's not actually
that scary so we both lived in San
Antonio in our past and in San Antonio
there's a train track and if you go to
the train track and first you dust the
back of the car with flour mm-hmm then
you put the car in park and then the car
just moves forward on its own over the
train track over the train track and
then when you get out at the end you see
the handprints of the ghosts that pushed
you did you do that I didn't do that I
wanted to work we did roll but we didn't
have handprints oh want me to explain
why yeah yeah okay okay so the the place
the location that is hat it looks
completely flat but there's actually a
small slope that's why the car rolls but
the reason why handprints show up on the
back of the car is because human hands
are greasy Oh
so normally when you're like you know
like if you have a clean car and you
touch the back of your car you leave a
greasy handprint and then when you dust
it with flour forward yeah the the
grease holds on to the flour and you
left with ghostly handprints oh that's
so cool it's your own handprint I think
the reason that we didn't see it on ours
as we only tested like the bumper which
isn't a thing you touch oh we have happy
the top like the back of that get the
back of the car yeah that's good that's
good
yeah that's nothing okay a preview for a
spooky scary
yes all right guys well thank you so
much for hanging out with us during
today's podcast if you share this with a
friend or a family member then nothing
scary will happen to you this Halloween
yes wait that sounds like a threat
[Applause]